good morning millennial good morning
Millennials welcome back to the morning
toast today's Tuesday July 18th 1616 and
that's it and we're toasty and we're
ready to hit you with all the toes I am
a little toasty my shirt is so wrinkly
today like it's borderline embarrassing
like I think you could probably see it
really no industry I don't mean oh man
why is it so wrinkly because I throw it
in a ball just like I do everything else
I understand I feel like my clothes are
sometimes wrinkly which is very
off-brand for me but I never take the
time I don't even like I have an iron
and an ironing board but I it says the
plastic on it and iron is not the way to
go the joy mini steamer that I got from
QVC that's the way to go or I just hang
it up in the shower with the shower on
hot and it doesn't work say a prayer or
I try and use my hair iron ya know also
doesn't work the shower thing does not
work no but you think it does then you
just feel better about yourself like you
also never leave enough time why I leave
it in there for a really long time than
my whole showers so steamy and then I go
in my makeup falls off yeah otro sure
Trail True Jackson VP steamy vibes only
steamy vibes only anyways we have
another amazing well actually we don't
know if it's amazing well around an
impasse together because we haven't done
it yet but we have another show that we
think is gonna be amazing well-rounded
anyhow right it's the 17th of July oh we
were both wrong okay that makes you feel
it's the 17th of July while July is just
cruising on back cruising on and I get
to August which is the worst month of
the year because it's just dead hot dead
boring dead everywhere oh my god okay
well yes it is the 17th I go to st.
Louis on the 19th sorry sill doubt and
then I go to Denver on the 21st which is
not sold out cuz it's a big-ass theater
so if you want to come tickets at girls
no job calm very exciting I want to go
to Denver I don't think that you do why
what's to do Colton lives in Denver
Denver and you know about to say right I
know what you're about to say but did
you watch a show last night
bits and pieces I didn't watch a minute
but I watched everything that was on
Bravo finally Bravo's Monday night
his back Housewives of Orange County
southern term sadhana which I stumbled
into and I'm glad for because I'm ready
to give it a second chance but please
tell us your amazing fantastic news and
I'm not jealous at all
Colton Underwood followed me on
Instagram last night I don't know what
like I just want to know what brought
him to that like what was he doing a
minute before do you know what I mean
like did he get was talking to someone
who follows me or like was he just in
his room but he on the explore page and
saw one of your posts I don't know so
I'm just was he watching the toast and
hearing us talk about him and Tia's
shipping them and defending him and
protecting him and I'll cause it's
definitely possible
it's definitely possible but I guess
that part wouldn't make sense cuz Biden
you follow me yeah it's okay when when
the time comes I'm gonna slide it today
yeah II don't think I've ever been so
jealous
oh really like and I didn't know that
this is what I would take right like
Harry Styles not jealous not jealous
Colton Underwood jealous okay now we
know what it takes samuel l.jackson not
jealous oh I would be jealous of samuel
l.jackson no Colton Underwood
definitely so we'll recap everything at
the end of the show I did watch bits and
pieces of The Bachelorette it was just
so terrible
um and I just I want to change where my
Monday night and Here I am enjoying it
you know here you are on Tuesday morning
having enjoyed your Monday and I went
thinking of the memories of the good
Monday night that I didn't spend
watching the master I spent my whole
Monday night in front of the television
and I managed to not avoid the back to
not watch The Bachelorette I spent my
whole literally I had a couple meetings
yesterday I got home at like 2:30 from
2:30 to literally midnight I did not
stop working we have so much going on we
have so much going on me like so many
major launches all at once I didn't even
eat dinner Wow me neither I looked up it
was 10:30 I'm like what I didn't eat
dinner either I looked up and it was
like it was like 8 o'clock and I was
like I can order dinner and eat dinner
late and feel fat or like I have you
just go to bed without somebody that was
me I'm like it's too late for dinner I'm
like you know what it wouldn't kill me
to like not do I literally thought it
won't kill me to miss a meal but then at
like 11:30 I was so hungry and I do have
a couple toasty toes that's fine
yeah no that's so crazy but you have the
like exact city no you're so busy we're
so busy because as you know cam toast is
in the final stages of preparation
organization tickets will be available
soon for patreon members and
a few days later for regular toasters
then we are working on merchandise
literally like the most premium
merchandise we're aiming I don't want to
make false promises aiming for an August
1st launch that would be ideal so let's
say August 15th so you know what
considering like how dead August is like
we're bringing it back to life with you
all of these launches no we're just like
we're business women like I felt like
such a business woman yesterday Look Me
in my Photoshop like literally just
making things I felt like such a
businesswoman yesterday that I actually
then went to look to buy a desk because
I work for my couch and now we need
desks we are gonna get a desk because
exact likes a desk but now it's for me
because I'm the businesswoman no but I
got a desk for me because Ben has like a
real office right and I never use it
like ever well I need to start sitting
at a desk because like pop my wrists and
my neck are breaking I can sit on my
vanity but then I'm just staring like so
I am also in the stages of like looking
for an apartment and I just I don't
think there's anything worse no no there
isn't it's when you actually physically
have to move yeah that's true that's
true but um I just I don't know where I
want to live I don't know what I want
and I just want a good deal and it's
hard to find like I want to steal you
know and what some one time because
you're living in a steal yes and you're
spoiled 100% like I I should be paying
like double my rent no you should be
paying like a thousand dollars more than
you pay and it would still be a good
deal uh-huh totally and I really
shouldn't be moving but like I really
need space and I'm I'm done with this
apartment like if I have to stay in this
apartment for one more minute I'm gonna
kill myself I'm done with it
for you yeah like I just walk in there
I'm like oh you know no I don't feel
that way still an amazing apartment and
I'd like it's just you've you've
outgrown it no I did a little weird
busting at the scenes and honestly I
blame Thea completely but like what I
really should do is like clean out my
closets and look at a new comforter and
like my whole apartment would be brown
speaking new and maybe vacuum but like I
just don't want it I'd rather move as
well you should
yeah except you can't beat that view and
that light no the light is great but
like there's so many downsides there's
so much like like I can't sit at my desk
until like 2 o'clock because the Sun is
always in my eyes you gotta wear
sunglasses literally on my desk I'm like
so I'm so ready I'm so ready I know what
you're gonna say ok well are you also so
right
to get into the past I stories that you
need to know before you wake up at take
a bite I'd be morning toast um I think
so yeah I think you're ready
I feel really ready for something like
that you know just and then you just
prepare yeah first story piggybacking
off of yesterday's chef Amazon's website
crashed as soon as prime day began this
is so crazy you guys and I have a lot of
thoughts about it
Amazon's website has been experiencing
issues for hours now due to heavy online
traffic on prime day the e-commerce
giant's made-up holiday designs to boost
sales
according to down detector calm Amazon
duck week that's a great website because
you know how we always think like is
Instagram down to Facebook down there's
website called down detector calm oh my
god that's genius because every time I
think instagrams down I just search
Instagram and Twitter and like a million
people are like it's Instagram now but
then of Twitter's down like I don't know
where to go you know exactly and also no
one notices when Twitter's down detector
that's such a good idea also speaking of
Twitter the morning shows is now on
Twitter and we got our real username at
the morning good toast is no longer a
southern morning show you guys we're
breaking news left right center making
memes left right center that making the
content left right center that's a long
time I go on Twitter is to make a meme
yep or to see what empty and John Doe
are saying yeah they've been honored in
they really happen okay
Amazon has been experiencing issues
since around 305 p.m. Eastern Time
yesterday with a large spike in reports
immediately after prime day officially
began at 3:00 p.m. Eastern Time
it's not clear how widespread the outage
has been according to downer that Turk
detector calm the outages restricted to
the US and it appears to still be
affecting large parts of California and
the New York and the New York as of 5:30
p.m. Eastern Time with a smattering of
smaller outages in the Pacific Northwest
and other parts of the country okay this
is so crazy because you just think
Amazon like would have their [ __ ]
together like they are the biggest
company in the world the biggest online
retailer they own like over 50% of the
marketplace and you would think that
they are beyond these things and I was
honestly so glad to see that they're not
I know it makes me feel good about like
when we have a technical difficulties
like so does Amazon but also it's like
Amazon is clearly taking over the world
and we're just letting it happen and you
know what fine you know like nothing bad
or like no human error has ever happened
to amaz right so it makes me like Amazon
they're just like us yeah they're just
people and even if they
to take over the world like they're
still gonna hit technological glitches I
mean I literally but that would be like
a good time for us to run away if it
ever happens I had a call with our mercs
crow three o'clock and I literally moved
it to 3:30 I'm like okay we move to 3:30
cuz I needed prime day I started
refreshing it like the pay just weren't
working and I'm like what is this and
then I go to the toaster troop and
everyone is up in arms about it
especially the toasters amazon prime
group toasters in their prime and I'm
like okay not everyone's having this
problem
you think Amazon they'll have a fix in
two minutes then I get caught up in all
the work that I'm doing in literally at
6 o clock I'm like oh it's definitely
better now go still no and I'm like you
know what [ __ ] these people they don't
deserve my money like you literally had
one job on Amazon Prime day and that's
just for your website to work and like
you couldn't do it
it's so crazy I have to be honest I'm so
happy about it like that's what you get
for making up a fake holiday jacking up
prices getting the whole world up and
arms buying your Amazon echo so you
couldn't record us doing god-knows-what
your dad was it you're canceled no so I
had a bunch of stuff in my cart before
and then with the glitch it all fell out
I'm like I'm not gonna go back and
search out of your car that was so
annoying so then I was like I was buying
dishwasher but you know I did things I
needed for my house that weren't even on
sale was just like a regular day on
Amazon like I got my makeup remover pads
which were not on sale I've got my
dishwashing stuff which was also not on
sale and I bought a Jade roller that was
like literally seven cents off a totally
way so you didn't buy it
no I did buy it oh I just bought then I
was like I'm in net I was like oh I
actually need stuff from Amazon none of
it was on sale and I just went like a
regular person to Amazon Amazon man get
your [ __ ] together so stupid never
thought I'd say that
yeah and like the deals aren't even real
as the morning toast explained yesterday
and like I thought would that that
article that we read from chatter was
just like haterade but it's very real
it's baby like we're always reading
haterade oh my god and to read also like
this is haterade like everything we did
was haterade it strictly
we just hate everything that other
people like yeah except we like the
Kardashians
yeah leave people like love to get home
and take off their bras like no I keep
mine on literally all day all night 24/7
I haven't watch this bra it's part of me
now III like to take my bra off now just
like things that ever went like okay
like ready
Chipotle like oh yeah
just like theirs I have two mindsets one
like things that everyone loves I
automatically hate uh-huh like we're
hold on what is it what is like everyone
love like what's like so like millennial
II like Chipotle like bye Khloe bye
Khloe or like okay hold on I just had it
give me two seconds two seconds two
seconds earpods like just things that
everyone liked it air pods whatever what
do I call them ear pods that's a much
better name for them just saying it is I
actually want a pair but then like also
things that are universally well liked
but that people love to hate I love like
the Kardashians like Taylor Swift like I
just like I I go the opposite of what of
what the world says because I'm an
individual thinker we're hipsters yeah
oh my God we're so music country music
I'm just so hip like Kiki I don't know I
don't know that is I don't get I don't
like I understand a lot of challenges
start I have no idea where the Kiki
challenge came from and the scale of it
like did you see Will Smith on the top
of a bridge that was cool with the drone
that was so crazy yeah but like who even
sings a song I don't know is it Drake
who is Kiki also is it Kim Kardashian is
it keke palmer they used to call kim
Keeks remember that's true and Kiki you
can call me and Kiki Nicci
[Laughter]
that's um that's theatre in my feelings
totally we should do it honestly me
probably crush it totally I mean we're
amazing
we should get you know we should get to
the query wrap it for us wait age'
a user power yeah so we can PR agent
Paola says hello if you don't get that
inside joke that is a very old breath
inside joke and if you do get that joke
you know what I'm singing the other day
it's like I can't believe I'm like will
you laugh very hard on the show I was
like I can't believe I've never peed in
my pants and I was like I'm no good with
Asia to Paulo yeah when you do another
dance segment like a live from like a
studio yeah only with Asia though yeah
or like someone else or Mikey
whoever's in town okay next story is
really sorry interest in speaking of
guests we have confirmed Eric pass on
the toast we'd be going back and forth
with him he's very busy cuz he said he's
working a lot but he made time for us
July 24th
Tuesday it's going down I'm wearing my
wedding dress
imagine if I showed up in my wedding
dress that would be so fun I'll get
ordained I'm gonna wear just all white
okay just to give up Bridal vibes
yeah actually been to order on ASOS like
they have like Bridal they have like
wedding dresses on a so it's that early
$10 oh my god I'm gonna get one okay but
you also said you were gonna wear a
wedding dress for the Peter Cronk
episode okay but like I would have worn
it for Peter but like it would have been
embarrassing to be like talking to Rob
Gronkowski and a wedding dress is that
why you didn't wear it yes okay so I
probably you're not you'll really wear
it for Derrick if you remind me I'm
gonna place an order after this is like
a really glamorous wedding dress that
it's gonna be so funny that will be
amazing and just like don't say anything
no of course not
okay next phrase really sad you guys
ladies of London star Adam L Nielson has
passed away and stars her friends hope
that her death was a hoax cuz that's the
new age that we live in like where you
read someone visit a hoax it's not a
hoax
she is dead animal Neil send the
aristocratic wild child best friend of
Kate Moss one time Alexander McQueen
muse and star of Bravo's ladies of
London has died at 49 her death was the
talk of the International social circles
over the weekend as pals had just seen
Nielsen at the lavish wedding of her
ex-boyfriend Lord Edward Spencer
Churchill to Kimberley hammer Strohm at
Blenheim Palace sources said Nielsen who
was once briefly married to Blue Blood
NAT Rothschild died on Thursday night
but bizarrely Nielsen's Instagram was
active on Saturday confusing even her
close friends who had heard the bad news
Annabelle is that you posted Nielsen's
former ladies of London co-star Marissa
Hermer as rumors of her death spread but
a jokey post of a man in the pool popped
up with the caption fatties get in first
what so he that was hacked I don't know
another pal privately hopefully wandered
to page six if it was all an elaborate
hoax
but by Monday multiple reports surfaced
that she passed away no cause of death
was revealed a London police rep
confirmed to page six that cops
responded Thursday night to a report of
a woman found deceased at an address
matching a Nielsen family home sources
told page six that Nielson seemed
distracted at the spencer-churchill
wedding in addition to the posthumous
Instagram post a number of darker posts
from Nielsen speed were scrubbed on
Saturday including a recent severe black
and white selfie with the caption my
current state of mind to which a
follower commented there may be no color
right now but
we'll come again don't rush or force it
and take care of yourself you're very
much worth it
a source told us that someone edited the
feed after her death and said she was
found by a family member
multiple calls to Annabelle's sister
Millie were not returned a retro Bravo
also did not respond to a request for
comment a profile in the British
telegraph in 2008 said Miss Nielsen's
extrovert personality is not limited to
the party scene she also flies
helicopters swims with sharks has ridden
a motorbike across Australia and
competed in a rally across the Himalayas
during winter that is so sad and like
for slalom Chuck
second of all like the fact that we
don't know what happened is like so
cryptic and that like someone there's
like a ghost on her Instagram is even
more cryptic but that is so like British
like in America it's like a well-known
person died like in two seconds you
would know what it was from you know
what I mean like only in London are they
like actually respectful and don't like
blast it everywhere right people are
asking if you can schedule the posts you
can't schedule Instagram posts and she
definitely didn't know you have like
don't use like bootleg xxx party yes I'm
like she's not the type to have used
that but it's just like so crazy because
like honestly like I remember I remember
her so well but like if I if you had
until you told me we were on FaceTime
like I like never would have thought of
her again in my life do you know what I
mean like I knew her well it's just so
crazy and like this feels close to home
and it's like we watch the show it feels
very close to home we I loved that show
and you know what's interesting is that
her in Caroline which starts good we're
such good friends on the show they kind
of came on the show together but
Caroline hasn't said anything on social
media okay like an hour before I before
he found out Caroline said I said scram
story was on a flight from Dubai to
Miami so I was like maybe she doesn't
know but did she get Wi-Fi I don't know
no but I checked this morning to see if
she posted something on her Instagram
did she not on her post maybe in her
stories but I didn't see anything no
it's so wild it's so wild it's so sad
but I just hoped like I just pray for
her family and that like they find peace
and it's just really sad no matter what
happened like yeah no it's just it's
literally the craziest thing ever and
it's crazy like she was so close with
Alexander McQueen yeah he was she was
his muse she really was so prestigious I
was reading more about her yesterday
after the news broke and like she's best
friends with Kate Moss and like Naomi
Campbell and it's what's crazy is that
she did a Bravo show right it's like
people on Bravo shows like to say that
the
best friends of Kate Moss but then you
find out like that they were just like a
pretend congressman from you know right
or like they met her at a party right
like everyone's really a fraud like she
was the real deal this yeah totally
like real fashion icon Muse yeah it girl
but like a priest not a real pop star
you know right but Caprice gave us so
much only one season I know that's all
she needs like yeah her she was so
divisive the first season that it forced
people to take sides on the show and
like really invested in it totally and
that's when I fell in love with Caroline
Stanbury and I love her to the say like
she is my favorite rival ebony Caroline
Stanbury has an amazing life but the
life she had on like season 2 we're like
she had a flourishing business the gifts
library like in a beautiful house like a
great family like she was in the in
control of everything and everyone like
that is the most amazing life and it's
different now it's still great but it's
just different and like I want that life
like for that one season no totally no
her life is still but now she has the
life where she lives in Dubai she has
her whole family with her like they're
still such a good family her husband has
like a great job there that's why they
moved there and she is just always
jet-setting like and she's like famous
now before she was just like cool a
socialite in a corner of London but now
she's like a worldwide international
superstar Caroline Stanbury prestige
worldwide totally I just like I love her
I love her and I really miss ladies of
London it was such a good show it was
but you know who I don't miss Sophie
Stanbury I just
she really irked me no I loved her until
she turned on camera right do not bite
the hand that fed you not only that if
you're gonna change your last name
because you're not even married anymore
right that was so and it's like
atrocious when Sophie and Caroline's
brother divorce mhm
Caroline took some side and it's like
you're not even gonna take Caroline's
side against juju balls totally she was
the one who I really didn't like Marissa
Hermer I know she was so high and mighty
cuz her husband like owned a cool Club
and like honestly there's nothing more
powerful than like being in control of a
cool restaurant like there really and
I'm being sick there's nothing more
powerful and she took advantage of that
power I'm like honestly I found her so
kind of setting and annoying she was
really good anyway she started off like
really sweet and cute like she's a cow
burning transcendence and she like knew
her place and was just like she wants
she was like so excited to become a
British citizen like she was really
sweet about everything but then she got
way too ahead of herself and she thought
she could go up against Caroline yeah
[ __ ] are you kidding no also the worst
ever Julie Montagu yeah I really love
sandwich no like its honestly impressive
how like deep in her family history is
but like she's just like some American
and like she doesn't care about it and
like I just I really didn't like and she
acts like better than re to the Earl
it's like this great responsibility
written and it's like no you get a
castle and yes you have to upkeep it but
you're on a Bravo show and now you bring
so much tourism there and like if you
can't make that [ __ ] work then that's
on you notice any of the capital T
literally her job was just to man the
gift shop and she couldn't handle it
what was the name of the castle it
starts with an M they talked about it
all the time hold on which no that's the
town or I'll have sandwich and I'm gonna
get all this pedo stuff
Casso right there was a big scandal with
the Earl of Sandwich a couple months ago
no were like years ago okay okay what's
called him
totally if you ain't drink every time
you hear the word mapperton on ladies
London you have to go to the hospital no
but then like Caroline like when like
there were so many rules at mapperton
remember and she was like I just want to
eat and I go to bed but also like a
lining like so like a little wrinkles
yeah was also weird very dramatic very
German told her from production like
your job is to be like the type of
person who's allergic to rules and she
like took it really seriously time she
was neurotic honestly everyone on that
show was a true gem a gem the girl from
the first season who was like Noel yeah
her husband her boyfriend was like in
the middle of like a crazy divorce and
like it was never-ending for sure she
was gorgeous my Martin scandal and her
has her boyfriend like was involved in a
divorce and like legal trouble yes yeah
but they've been really on to something
but like we weren't ready for it you
know now she like blogs for HuffPost
travel she oh my god what's sadder than
that like honestly it would be less sad
if he told me shudder I'm blog you know
of course it's more but like Juliet I'm
leeann's blog is the Jake
Juliet uh what was her Instagram name
it's just and now she got actually I but
she like a blog name yeah likes to like
didn't Julie I don't know something like
Lane like that and she's like she
doesn't have that many followers but
like she gets like work this is like I
think her full-time job yeah and her
husband's like super red she like shows
really need to care like she was in st.
Barths with Lindsay Lohan like she gets
around she does a good job no she
definitely post premium content and it
was just a little sad like watching on
the Indies of London like her trying to
like take pictures on st. Patrick's say
like being the drunken thirsty or like
when that when that other girl Caroline
remember the second Caroline the second
yes okay I'm coming Fleming brought her
to like Fashion Week and she was like
I'm doing this as a favor to Juliet cuz
blog like that was that that was very
sad also Caroline Fleming is a princess
of Denmark like that was so crazy yeah
no but she's divorced so like she's like
she's like she is so prestigious like
they just got such a great cast it was
such a an amazing show and I just I feel
like it's like a pretty wild like a
moment we're never gonna get back yeah
and like we didn't really know as it was
happening well it was until that's the
phrase you don't know what you got till
it's gone is so true and you really
don't even realize how true the phrase
is until something that you loved is
gone you know yeah you don't even
realize how much you loved it until one
of the cast members tragically passes
away and that's true get to talk about
it cuz we've never really gone into the
shadows of London because I feel like I
never like watched it on time I just
like always caught up on it like they
were never really having the girls on
watched up and slide like it wasn't like
a main Bravo show it's like Real
Housewives of Josiah which I've heard is
[ __ ] incredible why it's a the show
yes Tresh ire where's Josh I I don't
know it feels like the house has a
Melbourne but where do I even watch it
Melbourne plays on Bravo sometimes like
late at night and I've watched it and
it's wild the girls are out of control
and they speak English but they have
subtitles because they have the thickest
accents I don't know people are like so
crazy obsessed with HS I wasn't ladies
of London called Real Housewives of
London I think they wanted to like
differentiated it's like a new show but
we also have a chest Shire and also like
these were like real like ladies like
they were like accomplished they had
businesses they were very wealthy where
I was like Real Housewives like a little
trash here so let's you have called in
Real Housewives of London would have
been I think an insult and I don't think
they would have gotten Caroline yeah or
the princess also like most some were
married Annabelle wasn't married
I wasn't married well most house I
manatees yeah but they all start out
married that's you can't get on the show
being single really yeah what new
housewife comes on they all get divorced
granny Lana okay well she was an anomaly
that doesn't count okay and she was
brought on the show like naturally first
by Adrian he brought her yes that's
what's so crazy because she totally
turned turned on her but like Adrian but
also this really brings you on like
doesn't is fake that's like Doreen and
Teddy Mellencamp okay like Tamara and
that woman who she said like their first
time meeting up on the show on the
episode that's saying she knew in 60
Parris yeah that was a little far from I
need to talk about that woman because I
had questions yeah she's a party planner
and an attorney I don't get it right and
why can't they say lawyer what's the
difference they keep saying attorney I
don't know there must be a difference
there must be a difference okay I think
attorneys go to court that's what it is
okay next up Kylie Jenner and Travis
Scott sizzle in GQ and Tinsley
she came on signal and they discussed
the Kardashian curse well cuz like
Tinsley which I say that I miss your
whole I was Kylie Travis okay oh yeah
sizzling on the cover of GQ talking
about the Kardashian curse its Kylie
Jenner and Travis Scott's world and
we're just living in it beacuse August
issue features the beauty mogul and the
rapper on its cover cementing their
status as a power couple it marks their
first interview and photo shoot since
they got together in the spring of 2017
and it makes Travis nervous he was
whispering to me the whole time Jenner
says after the photo shoot with Powell a
kudaki
he just doesn't like taking the photos
Travis admits he's impatient as a
[ __ ]
during photoshoots although he prefers
them to be photographed by the paparazzi
quote I hate when people randomly take
pictures of me the watch rapper says in
the magazine I look crazy as [ __ ] in
them no lineup no nothing Jenna and
Scott met during Coachella
neither remembers exactly where and hit
it off immediately that's kind of weird
they don't remember like weird right he
happened to be on horses she decided to
join him
I really jumped on the bus and then we
rode off into the sunset I did the whole
tour with him she recalls
even then Jenner wasn't worried about
what her family might think of the world
wouldn't romance my whole family knows
that I do whatever I'm going to do I've
been that way my whole life I don't
really answer to anybody I live on my
own and I just rode off into the sunset
we had a lot of downtown time it
Organic she says how many times is she
gonna say right off into the sunset
right anew so for her quote and we we
just go to these random cities we got to
not be who we really were like if we
were in LA I feel like it would have
been way different everything happened
for a reason we weren't going out as
Kylie and trav we would just be in
Cleveland walking the street for hours
we would go on walks and no one would
bother us that's like so nice I didn't
know any of this happened did I mean
that's the thing about Kylie she's so
complex and like every interview minute
every moment like you just see a new
side of her but it's like so this time
that she's talking about is also when
she was filming life of Kylie right
that's like during and after Coachella
but she was riding off into the sunset
with Travis no I don't know the time so
it's like diddly squat about Travis no
the timing is all Shaddai because of
Tyga too but like what I've learned from
life of Kylie and just like being a
Kylie fan in general is like she really
hates being famous like she loves his
success and she loves her family but
like the non like the the lack of
privacy and just like the lack of like
mental health I think like really gets
her which is why she's so private so
this makes sense like her being obsessed
with like Cleveland do you know a
hundred percent and I understand how
they could like fall in love there so
when they find out they're having a baby
it's nothing but good rice but at the
time - she's a little weird to me she
stole my [ __ ] I'll a question mark no
it's just it's blurry it's all blurry
but this could talk about the cover for
a minute yes but there's like so much to
the story so much to unpack okay the
covers are being shown - yes talk about
it for a second okay first of all she is
that scar on her leg that I don't know
what it's run but she like loves to show
it off which i think is like so brave
you know and I love that she put it in I
just I'm not I'm just not here for the
ass like Kim - like I've been meaning to
talk about this first of all I can't
believe they still to this day pretend
it's real do you know what I mean like
are you kidding come on and became is
like so obsessed with being skinny and
her body would be so different if she
didn't have that ass and it looks so
stupid like back in the day I think she
really did have like a big butt like
Margo yeah but she had like six eyes and
a big ass and like people loved it and I
loved it - but then she got so carried
away with it she looks so stupid now I'm
like I just I really want to live in a
world where they don't and Chloe's is so
poorly constructed like she literally
looks like she's wearing a diaper at all
times like Kylie's is like a little bit
more natural yeah like she doesn't look
insane but like it's also it's not real
and I just don't like it
and like they're obsessed with being
skinny they want skinny thighs you can't
have skinny thighs and a big ass you
need to have a load-bearing legs member
mm-hmm like but I don't understand
because they don't have butt implants
they have injections I think they've
been doing them now for 10 years and
that's how we we've reached this level
of capacity but how come they can't just
get like liposuction of the but they
don't want to know Kim definitely
doesn't want that Jackie yes she does
no she there's you have to maintain that
athlete it doesn't you don't just inject
it and then it lasts but like there's no
way that she likes how like that looks
now it's terrible it's really terrible
and it's like a joke and it's the one
thing about them that like I just can't
make seriously no and that's the one
thing I won't get on board with totally
it's bad and it's so silly she's like so
upset when pictures of her are leaked on
the beach and it's like what do you
expect you're gonna look like right no
no like to haven't asked like that your
thighs have to be like strong and big
and like she wants tiny thighs in a day
that's not realistic no that's that
doesn't make sense like physically yeah
no science load-bearing she needs Elon
Musk to tell her totally I'm just like
I'm not I can't get I can't get behind
it and it's like every time I see a
picture it's like the one thing I look
at and I always think about like hmm how
interesting would be to like not have
like to have a Kim with just like a
normal ass well then maybe she wouldn't
have been like such a phenomenon like
now we've reached maximum capacity yeah
like over the years it's been growing
and it's like Kim's ass and it's like
that's kind of separated her from like
the other basics who are trying to be
just like her right but like I don't
think all these girls would have fake
asses if it weren't for Kim that's crazy
now there's a couple of big asses out
there like JLo different no but JLo has
a real ass that's true and JLo has like
the thighs sneaky [ __ ] hers is fake
for sure and cardi B who had said hers
is fake
oh is it yeah I never noticed her about
before yeah I hadn't noticed I didn't
notice me there I'm just I don't like
the big butt trend like the fake big
butt trend like Margo it's like a real
big ass and she has like big ish bigger
thighs just import it like a large
natural Margo doesn't even have a day
guys like Margo just has like a booty
with like a bubble but yeah like Kim had
originally know Kim had a big ass like
bigger than most yeah okay fine but it's
just like the charade is like it's
lasted too long it's been 10 years I
agree give it up and like or at least
tell us that it's fake like I can't
believe she's still to this day but like
a fall on her
like it's so not I don't want it's like
she went on Tyra and got a butt scan and
like yeah there's no implants in there
and like you just thought but like let's
zoom in on your skin and see how many
injectable holes are in there and I love
plastic surgery like I don't mind that
they all have different faces than when
they started it's cool like it's it's
fun but like the ass is stupid you know
I agree it's silly okay
months into their relationship to Kenner
discovered she was pregnant something
she chose not to speak about publicly
until her daughter's stormy Webster was
born in early 2018
it was crazy Scott says of West
Webster's birth I was there through the
hell the epidural and [ __ ] crazy
at one point Mark Anthony green asked
Jenner and Scott about the Kardashian
course ie the belief that almond who
goes through the Kardashian orbit end up
flaming out Scott isn't worried that he
might end up gone like Scott Disick or
Lamar Odom quote I don't even be looking
at [ __ ] I don't be looking at
[ __ ]
Kylie actually likes me for me he says
adding I'm on my slightly for me I'm on
my own Island
so hey come over there to astral world
I'm not into all the other [ __ ] I don't
get involved I'm over here kylie is
different green shares his theory about
the Kardashian curse with Jenner saying
maybe it's just extremely difficult to
fly this close to the Sun you were built
for this level of celebrity Travis and
the other men weren't Kylie was
definitely built for this level of
celebrity I just want to say I think
it's super impressive but like nobody's
saying that Travis is too and that like
Scott to say it Lamar Odom like or not
okay also but Travis is not nearly as
famous as Kylie
no but he's me like he's amazing and
like and he's so respected I totally
agree he's major and he makes a ton of
money but like Fame wise I'm like pride
to see why it's like he's not even close
to Kylie or any of the Kardashians but
he's still super super famous but I'm
just saying like Kylie at the age of 22
be like under enormous like pressure
like that like all the Kardashians are
super strong when it comes to like fame
but Kylie's more famous than any of them
and she's stronger than any of them I
think it's super impressive it is really
impressive also like the Kardashian
curse is [ __ ] like and I can't
believe people even give it the time of
day like to put it on these women that
these men are failures meanwhile the
elastic misogyny classic misogyny and
you know what it's not the Kardashian
curse it's the Hollywood curse this
isn't exclusive to the Kardashian people
so out of control get addicted to drugs
and sex Lamar Odom is the first person
in Hollywood to do drugs the first
basketball player right look please
shelli's with your misogynistic rhetoric
so insulting like it is Lamar and Scott
are just ill-equipped victims of
Hollywood and fame and that goes back
years James Dean James Dean he tried to
get out he's living in Canada James Dean
I wonder if he heard that song he did
because he's a lot because he was live
in Canada listening on the radio I made
up Canada does true no I can't oh yeah
yeah
who else has fallen victim a Rob loser
and that's what Kim is saying like
everyone Kim did an interview at
beautycon got a lot of people attacked I
said like defending Kylie basically she
was saying like with all the backlash
about the self-made thing on Forbes like
Kylie never addresses it but Kim feels
like super protective and like always
wants to address it and Kim is out and
about more so someone asked her about it
and she was just like there's so many
people who have been in Kylie's position
that came from like successful family
and like literally end up strung out on
drugs like their Kim's like you know
many people I know who came from
successful families and aren't even
close to doing what Kylie does even the
successful ones aren't even close to
Kylie likes so for people to not give
Kylie credit is so stupid she literally
said exactly what we said on the show
and not that I'm saying she watch it but
it's like we are just the same no we
thought and I'm telling you like Kim
really likes to reward people who are
like loyal to her and I don't think that
Kim coming on our show is like a crazy
thought like I think she might do it
like in like a year like yeah we have to
get there and also she needs to like be
promoting something than that she has to
reach the Millennials right no I'm just
saying like I know a lot of her
publicists definitely watch our our
stuff and like she just likes to go
where she's comfortable like she doesn't
need to go on GMA because she is GMA so
like where whatever interview she does
is gonna be that's what she does another
comfort like fake magazines like
Wonderland you know like yeah she
doesn't need to be on the cover of Vogue
because whatever interview she does is
just gonna get as many reads as Vogue so
she could bring Jimmy to us GMM though
good morning anyways this interview is
very enlightening I'm glad they're being
a little bit but because their
relationship has been confusing and it's
even been confusing now like are they
totally together what is their situation
do they live together well this is also
what's weird I don't think so and like
you have to separate real life from the
blinds I know
and the blinds saying the blinds are not
forgiving there
kind what do they say the blind say that
like Kylie's doing anything to keep
Travis she buys him cars like he wants
out and that Kris Jenner it's like
orchestrating this whole thing just so
that Travis doesn't leave yeah that's it
okay well you know people that
relationships have their up and down Oh
women want to keep their man and won't
do anything to keep them we vibe man car
I would would maybe wouldn't man just so
I said when the dragons are about people
that I hate I'm like yeah it's Celina
but then when they're dumb people that I
love it like it has to be wrong
something I'm like and she's wrong all
the time even the broken clock is around
twice today it's just like I refuse to
believe it but it actually kind of makes
sense total and it was the same but he
said the same things about Tyga so maybe
Kylie just likes to please everyone see
that was a possibility right and it's
like she has all this money what's the
point you're not gonna spend on the
people that you love totally okay this
next story is just so out of the box and
it's like when you hear it you're gonna
be like what show am i watch it okay
Goldman Sachs's next CEO is a part-time
electric dance DJ is that crazy Goldman
Sachs is next leader isn't your typical
investment maker David Solomon has been
named as a successor to CEO Lloyd Blank
fine who was stepping down September
30th Solomon is a part-time electric
dance deejay who spins records around
New York and Miami clubs under the
nickname DJ D soul have you heard of him
mm-hmm I kind of stumbled into it as a
hobby and now I just do it for fun
Salomon said in the podcast last year he
also does podcasts maybe he'll do this
one Salman was interested in club and
EDM music and saw them as growing
businesses he took a winding route to
the brink of one of Wall Street's
highest profile jobs
Solomon 56 Mader majored in political
science at Hamilton College random one
of his first jobs out of school in the
mid 1980s was selling commercial paper
and junk bonds at Drexel Burnham Lambert
Thunder flew
exactly after Drexel claps Salomon moved
to now-defunct Bear Stearns very sad
where he rose to become head of the
firm's investment banking division in
1999 Salomon took a risk by jumping to
Goldman it was a step back Sam until the
New York Times last year I was running a
division of the firm and I went and took
a job running
Salman came to Goldman right after a
moment of palace intrigue Hank Paulson
then Goldman's co-chairman had helped
stage a coup against fellow co-chair Wow
this is so wild here's the thing
he sounds wholly unqualified just from
what you read but whatever it's like
does he still teach I could we got him
to deejay like a birthday party no he
definitely still deejays and this story
is like showing me like he went to
Hamilton College which is like a few
miles away from court and very similar I
could be the next CEO of Goldman Sachs
not her today I had heard it was between
you and David Solomon I know I know and
he is more qualified and established but
my time will come is what they all said
know you as a woman you're always being
thought of well yeah classic misogyny
rearing its ugly head again
it's okay guys I got this job and I'm
really happy about it
it's being in tune with what's necessary
he's excused to be in tune with what's
necessary when there was the Twitter
account Gs elevator do you remember yes
it was a Twitter account that was really
popular and it was very real it was
someone I don't think they ever found
out who they did he wrote a book and
he's very public now oh yes he worked at
holman Sachs and he basically just used
to tweet things that people were saying
in the elevators and I go so douchey
like you know the guys who we're
critical mints acts like like I believed
frat brothers Wall Street
yeah wolf of Wall Street and like they
would just say like the lamest things
about like doing cocaine and like having
sex with girls on the weekends and he
would like tweet it out and he got
really popular I didn't appear in a book
he wrote a book like about his time
working there and apparently he's really
good I actually wanted to read it but
yeah Goldman Sachs is wild you guys also
apparently David Solomon is a pioneer in
his field
he's been hiring women women in the
banking industry before anyone would
give us a shot go David
maybe he'll hire us yeah we could be
analysts I definitely see finance fiscal
trends like in everyday life and I just
papered the whole fiscal family yeah and
like when I when I read the paper
I see the stocks I mean we read CNN
money every day now that who we have to
CNN money stories today that's X up by
dew points the Dow is higher than it's
ever been
yeah but you know but the doubt do
bubbles the bubbles gonna burst the Dow
Jones no I was I went to the stock
exchange twice you know what's that
first Bueller like
deep trades thank you it's really loud
you can talk so they're trading with
each other like oh my god it's all like
it's Morse code that's crazy
it's vascular of course when they go to
the stock exchange and then the guy is
like imitating oh I didn't realize
that's what he's doing craziness but now
I'm sure with the introduction of
technology that has changed like you can
just text someone like hey can I get two
piles of an ounce that please
I want to ring the bell I never got to
ring the bell I stood next to someone
who rate you know we need to do this is
a great goal for us it's very go public
we need to go public ring the bell it's
a big goal it's lofty goal can any
company go public or doesn't have to be
sick like it's successful one has to
take us public no I don't I think we can
take ourselves public no we need like
Jonah Hill and wealth of Wall Street to
take Steve Mann in public you know what
I'm saying like what qualifies you to
get public you have to be profitable we
are sort of well yeah you know like I
saw an episode of Drop Dead Diva which
you didn't like but it's like all about
every episode is like a different legal
matter and this one guy maybe it was
interrupted yeah was he made himself a
publicly traded company and that his
shareholders could buy a piece of him
and decide what he does with his life
that's how I fell in love with a woman
and like had to get out of this hole and
the shareholders didn't right so it was
super interesting to him like a fat guy
came to become public so good the toast
that's true but also it's a TV show so
and then I was watching Mad Men and they
were ready to go public like they had
all these accounts they were profitable
they were in a really good spot but then
they lost Jaguar and they couldn't go
public why though right like what are
the qualifications throwing public will
look it into it yeah any of it you
bankers out there well we just need to
have Steven Salomon if I'm only going
public with David Simon of course under
Goldman Sachs's wing who knew there were
so female-friendly who knew they were so
like EDM friendly honestly justice for
girls who work in finance like I'm sure
they have to put up with a lot and
you're the real heroes for sure and
justice for girls who worked in finance
30 years ago because you put up you with
even more yeah totally so crazy wolf of
Wall Street like it's so crazy
it's though it's pizza what it's like
why is it so good you know cuz Leonardo
DiCaprio and Margot Robbie and Joe and
it's like cast too perfect I still can't
believe that he didn't win an Oscar for
that or for anything other than the
Reverend the revenant
Reverend Reverend the revenant I walked
out of it it was literally the worst
movie ever he was getting attacked by
there and I couldn't decide if the bear
was having sex with him or trying to eat
him it was so disgusting
ran out and yes I get it like he worked
he worked harder for the revenant
probably than he did in other movies but
that does not an Oscar make no look I
can't believe he didn't win for Titanic
like he has so many What's Eating
Gilbert Grape
Django he was amazing with the teeth oh
my god it's crazy maybe
wait there's so many wolf of Wall Street
what else is he in a lot yeah like um
Great Gatsby
you know that's not that's indeterminate
that was like Confessions of a Teenage
Drama playing with all the like we are
people floating but okay we have a lot
of information about going public okay
read read me loud it's better to stay
private so you don't have to deal with
shareholders okay that's not my question
but then you will have to be bound by
corporate America again is the toast of
private partnership or an LLC you need
equity investments think of going public
think of going public like going
democratic made for the people by the
people are you found lesson ll so those
are just trade mark on the toast friend
both catch me if you can Jango shutter
island' shutter island' did you see that
movie it's the craziest movie I just
can't like there's like something hot
baby ater okay something happens at the
end of shutter island' that is like so
crazy here's the thing like I almost
wanted to tell me cuz I that's not even
on my list of things I need to say okay
can I tell you oh god no no please
please it's really crazy okay and I
watched a movie once and once I saw it I
was like so obsessed then I wanted to
like watch it with other people so they
could be like tricked at the end - okay
and I forgot - what we watching it let's
just watch it you're saying I should
watch it
no you won't like it it's not really not
your temperament it's the premise Leo
DiCaprio is a cop or like a detective
with and his partner they go to this
island called shelter shelter Shutter
Island where there's this like really
old mental institution and they're doing
like a huge investigation to see if
they're like treating people unfairly
and Oh a girl goes missing sorry a girl
is missing and they're there to find the
girl okay that sounds good I'll watch it
no please let me tell you what if I
don't want you tonight then you could
tell me tomorrow you told me I could say
it please I mean you could tell everyone
it's making it sound good it's really
good okay but it's not your vibe I know
you I know but you know sometimes I see
a movie that's not my vibe Sully and
it's makeup my favorite movie okay well
now I just told you that there's like a
big twist so now you're gonna be looking
for the twist okay I'll I'll forget it
okay fine if you don't want you tomorrow
I'm telling you okay you guys remind me
in the comments tomorrow to ask Jackie
if she watched Shelter Island Shutter
Island whatever I try Shelter Island to
them okay did the final story already
for at CNN Monday course Netflix added
five million customers but Wall Street
is panicking Netflix is such a
juggernaut that it only added 5.2
million subscribers last quarter and
everyone is hitting the panic button the
streaming company gained about 1 million
fewer customers that had expected it now
has about 130 million customers
worldwide the media industry has turned
itself upside down to do battle with
Netflix cable companies and movie
theaters are losing consumer customers
in droves they'd all love to have the
problem that Netflix had last quarter
yet Netflix is socks tank about 13
percent and after I was trading Monday
so while Street is freakin getting rid
of Netflix even though they're
successful and they're profitable but
they're not as successful and profitable
as they should be ok but also here's the
thing people like this is why I should
work in finance because I could have
guessed this because Netflix first of
all there's 7 billion people in the
world but I would say most people like
our on their family account and like
that let's say like a family's for
people you're automatically cutting 7
billion by 1/4 by 3/4 what's that 7/3
what's 3/4 of 7 Wow 1.7 okay so we have
1.7 billion then you have to count for
people who don't watch TV a people like
Amish people people who don't have TVs
like who live in like tribes like half
500 million right then you have to count
for people who are like babies like you
know like a toddler they're part of the
family can't compromise okay fine so
what we're we're 500 people can't afford
it people get reported right 350 says
you for sure 350 we're up to 350 million
okay so now they're at 130 like of
course they're gonna start slowing down
they're almost at the peak amount of
people like there are only so many
people in the world who are eligible to
pay for Netflix there are only so many
families in the world who are avid
eligible right so it's like I could have
seen this coming
you know I'm shocked it didn't happen
sooner and on reveal day there was a
crazy blind about Netflix we read it no
I didn't tell me in a second but also
it's like just like we were saying we
could have seen this coming
yet Wall Street didn't therefore they
need us as analysts a brakeman no I've
never he could have told you this like I
don't know why people are surprised by
it but here's the thing no it's really
that family plan that's [ __ ] every
100 and you account for sharing and you
have to account for Netflix and chill so
now everyone's watching together on one
account half of 350 175 we're up to 130
but here's the thing this is what then G
said about Netflix there's like a common
trend in Hollywood of like movie studios
and like just cable networks just
spending non-stop and eventually
thinking it'll turn profitable so like
what Netflix is doing is what other like
studios networks have done before but
has never worked it's just like throwing
all your money at like creating content
yeah and like they just signed a 200
million dollar deal with Adam Sandler
like that's one person you know and 300
million dollars with Ryan Murphy like
they're just non-stop they're just
getting they want all the shows all the
time that gives so much original content
like I don't even know what's theirs
like I have theirs Netflix shows that
I've never even heard of where does I
feel like when Netflix originals were
first coming out every time there was a
new one you heard about it yeah no I
read this not even through empty that
Netflix is spending millions and
millions of dollars said it does not
have hoping that it will turn profitable
and it has yet to like Netflix is losing
money as we speak right now it's like
the peak we're at peak Netflix right so
they're telling their investors that
like all this content it's like gonna
turn you know at a certain day and it's
like that's how movie studios in the
past have failed and like gone bankrupt
so maybe Netflix isn't OK in the world
but like if never goes out what are we
gonna do you know no I mean its original
I don't they got ahead of themselves
like I was I mean you know those show I
was happy paying eight $8.99 for like
all the movies and all the TV shows that
are not a Netflix original apart from
like Seinfeld not being on like a bunch
of you had to buy on Amazon but like for
the most part I was having with like a
wide range library of TV and movies
so you know it's also weird it's like
Netflix has everything but it actually
has nothing look but anytime they go to
our to Netflix if I don't have something
in mind like oh I'm I'm want to watch
Mad Men like I watch trailers for an
hour and fall asleep or like when you
have a movie in mind and you go to it
it's not on ya like that nobody have it
like it was only on for five minutes and
Hannah Montana forever season was under
three minutes totally it's like why
didn't the resources lead Obama their
licensing why does movies have to meet
leave Netflix licensing I send the
license
totally it's a Cobra's job it was to
keep Hannah Montana archived on Netflix
should be fired fired fail you failed
yeah totally failed us okay let's jump
into TV cap sniffles last night was a
big night for TV via the Real Housewives
of Orange County we had the Bachelorette
I'll be inside of the term Savannah
which I don't watch okay Real Housewives
of Orange County um I was actually
excited when I came back to because I
felt like there was there's so much
being built up because last season was
so disappointing I would say how much
happened in real life
off-camera in between seasons that like
now we're catching like Shannon and
David are divorced Kelly and Michael are
divorced vicki is in good graces with
the women who cameras husband is sick
Vicki set up David beador right there
have been so many news she sent up
Michael Dodd sorry yeah there have been
some we've reported on so much I just
happened to see it finally playing out
is very exciting David beador posting an
Instagram with his new lady love which
we reported on Valentine's Day so it's
all we get to see it all playing out and
that's excited and they're being very
dramatic with editing which I'm loving
and it's like I know that they know that
they have to bring impress this season
and that's the only reason why I'm Vicki
and Tamra and Channing ya know of all
the franchise's the ladies of OC I think
depend on it most like financially
especially Tamra and like they not even
financially just like they do not want
to be kicked off like Tamar getting
kicked off the show would literally be
the worst thing that ever happened to
her same as Shannon Shannon Stein was
single mom and she has a QVC deal that's
really success successful only because
of the show like they rely on it so much
so like they're gonna work overtime the
season to make it successful and I have
faith I do have faith first of all I'm
everyone's moving Tamra moved into a new
house which I was so excited about I
love a good move a little glow up except
she was being like so
he about it was like weirding me out
right and her kitchen had way too many
built-in shelves I really didn't like it
oh I liked her kitchen I liked our whole
house I I didn't understand why she was
more proud of it no she was it's she's
bigger than her old house but like I
think just in terms of some of the other
ladies she stills a smalls house well
actually not now not now no but she was
like saying it's not a big like she I
don't know she was really downplaying it
where I feel like it's such a big
accomplishment it's such a nice house
and the outdoor space is so pretty like
right that's what she said she needs to
because she's gonna have to move back to
the hotel right like you were living in
Eddie's bachelor pad I don't even
realize that I didn't know that either
because I always thought it was
decorated really nice I think they redid
it together yeah but like be proud of
yourself like you're moving into a new
home that's so exciting
totally and like honestly it's really
sad that like Eddie who's like literally
the picture of health work owns a gym
works out every day teaches Emilien
classes like even he isn't like has
health problems so this just further
encourages me not to work out no cuz
like it can happen to anyone it's even
in listening and like scary especially
because it seems as though I mean I
don't understand what it gets work
actually is and I've never even like the
heard of it no and like from usually
like you get a surgery and like it's
done like they look up the surgery and
found more problems and we've been
reporting on this for a while so like I
think only over the course of the season
like it only gets worse that's so sad
but so far it seems like things are okay
right now cuz you haven't heard anything
yeah no news is good news
amen so then Shannon Kelly both moved
Shannon moved into a very sweet home her
couch is horrible but other than that
everything looks really good she's a
great homemaker and watching Ashley
is a great homemaker watching that the
downgrades of the homes was really sad
like that or it they should have never
been of that how my god the homeopathic
like it had crystals in the walls there
was no Wi-Fi because they couldn't deal
with like that electric current that was
the most epic house I think in housewife
history I really agree like it was done
the basketball court that they would
play it like the men they can go on it
why did they ever move no and I think
I've heard that Shannon has family money
and David is very successful in
construction so what I just I but they
didn't explain why they move they just
said they were downsizing when when
someone says downsizing you assume it's
because of financial reasons nothing
ever came out about their kind great
that's what I'm saying so what why move
to that terrible rental well maybe they
were building like a new house may be
adjusted if they wanted to be in a
different area who knows whatever what
Kelly
I've never even started breaking ground
on a new house or looking for one
what Chanin hasn't had with her kids is
better than the rental they were in that
rental was terrible I totally agree oh
my god
I had a great view but everything else
was terrible no the house is really nice
and it's the perfect place for her to be
right now but I want her to get a home
that she can make her own just like I
feel like that's her pride and joy and
she's really good at it except her kids
look so [ __ ] sometimes they are in the
aren't they're actually really good kids
and sweet kids but like they have a lot
more attitude
you don't even imagine what we were like
that capture they're so cute like yeah
that would be us like in a band
no they really like remind and not that
we're similar to them at all but like I
just feel like you're having three girls
similar age like very close in age all
with their own stuff going on single mom
like I just feel like I can relate to
them I actually love Vicki's house like
it's been the same forever it's just
like so OC well honest and compared to
some of the other homes we're seeing I'm
like whose house is this
right she lives in a gated community all
the houses look the same like she's a
great outdoor space like but I loved the
outdoor space in Tamra's new house
that's what you have to strike me here
he was so cute so Gurney's yeah it was
great okay and then Kelly also moved to
a townhouse and like that was truly sad
I I was looking down at my phone when
they showed the outside so I missed it
by the way I was for some reason
obsessed with the houses I rewind I
reminded three times because they didn't
really show the outside of Tamara's
house because it was a movie truck in
front of it so I was like so everyone
did then I was looking down for Kelly's
and I also rewinded and then oh no I was
looking down for the new housewife and I
really wanted to see her house and it
was very nice now I don't I remember it
but I was just for some reason obsessed
with the house but I know I'm a process
of the houses because I mean now that
we're just like women and you're looking
for apartments like it means more to us
also but it's a big house is a true sign
of wealth
total it isn't it isn't because like oh
you could have a big house with like no
furniture she's like what a lot of like
sacred speaking yes like Teresa Giudice
right exactly
no but like that big house is a sign of
so much right a house there's a lot
about a person no but even when they
were on top of the world you worked in
the house is empty right cuz they
weren't on top of the world right but
now they're like send me back and
there's the house is literally still
empty but I think the house is just so
big even it was filled with furniture it
would still look empty right but that
has this iconic no it can never be sold
but here's what's unfortunate man Theo
see it's like we there is no house it's
like Real Housewives glamour like a rose
was gonna be was
and her last one wasn't challenged but
this season like it's a little too real
for me I couldn't agree more things
things I got an extremely pudding the
real in real housewives yeah okay
Callie's apartment a first saw I [ __ ]
love Kelly and her attitude
it's like Jim Shannon needs to take a
sip of whatever Kelly is drinking like
she would like she's obsessed with her
new apartment even though it's far
sadder than her last house by the way
because literally I [ __ ] love Kelly's
house loved Kelly's house decorated the
outside it's like it's a beach house
like it's unassuming but then inside
it's literally my dream door it's Malibu
Barbie's dream house like I used to love
it it's it was gorgeous and done it's
obvious that she took a lot of the
furniture cuz it her house is stacked
with furniture now totally but it's like
what she's gonna pay for a storage unit
right but no she took like a six bedroom
house and put all the furniture to a two
bedroom apartment and she's living her
best life and of her attitude is great
her attitude is great when she was like
we're living in this too they showed the
picture of the old house in new house
she's like we're now we went from 8,000
square feet to a two-bedroom and I love
it
it's just like she doesn't seem like sad
at all where Shannon is just like
exuding sadness and clearly their
situations were different in like Kelly
and Michael was clearly very mutual they
had been separated before Shannon and
David was not like sharra shannon is
very much in love with David but like
you just need to pick yourself up and
move on and know that he's not coming
home like yeah it's just it's really sad
like Shannon is such a great girl and
like she just needs to put herself out
there and just if her attitude change
like her girls like if they weren't you
know they're they're turning on her the
season you see it in the previews and
honestly the coming of Shannon beador
has been a long time coming and I know
you stand her and I do too but like last
season she was out of control
but she every one's going through
something but like you use that as an
excuse when you like someone you know no
one I yes and no like okay her world her
family everything is crumbling around
her she's gained so much weight for a
woman who's been skinny her whole life
like that is shocking and what the way
that she acted she was just like an
angry person taking out on people
telling she got a DUI arrested craziness
like 20 by the way she was only taking
out on Libby and Peggy who needed it
know and Kelly and sorry I stand by the
fact that Lydia was in a weighing for
sure but like she really didn't do
anything wrong
Lydia was horrible I only wish you were
here to season with her [ __ ]
friendship whisper [ __ ] she was
trying to shut Shannon out of the
too much I wish she could come in ones
friends now but you're still gonna pick
on chancy peace with honey ins comment
on Bravo what job and live Instagram her
she was like Shannon can't even keep a
man what's wrong with her she's out of
the shield I despise hands down the
worst housewife of all time mostly
because she ruined a franchise but when
we used to recap OC last season like
literally all we could do was talk about
Peggy and ego they were I'm the devil
I'm just so glad that they're gone and
there was a scene when they're driving
to in this episode where they're driving
to the ropes course and it's Vicki
Shannon and Tamara and Kelly and like
they are just like that is what we need
uh-huh honey it's like each of them the
reason might work so else cuz each of
them are crazy strong personalities but
so different it's like no one is
competing with the other no but because
they're so strong it's like literally
they're radioactive together and
especially what we need like stepped on
the rope and like wouldn't fit her when
they're together
it's literally like Mentos and Coke like
they're explosive they're also crazy
honestly the only one was semi in touch
with reality its Tamara and she is like
weirdly enough like that she offers like
a very short fuse know for sure but
she's really like the calming force in
comparison to the other three ladies but
like Kelly is so crazy like I'm so
afraid of her but I love her and
honestly I want credit because I stand
Kelly the first season and you hated her
and if she was wild and I saw the true
Kelly and I'm so happy for her and like
honestly if she plays her cards right
like this show could really change her
life and like he definitely has like now
without Michael and without the house
like this show could change her life she
needs like a thing or a business like
yeah and then she'll be set okay let's
talk about the new housewife yeah what's
her name Emily I don't know attorney
attorney slash party planner I thought
that was so weird cuz I had heard that
she was an attorney and then when Tamara
was introducing her she's a she planned
my party last year my ghost she's a
pretty better and she's an attorney at
night that's not right no it's so weird
you're an attorney like you don't need a
second job right like and you can't have
a second job like I don't even have time
I let her husband like gchat at her
saying I want to get married like which
I think she thinks is a cute story but
it's not also like it's cute sounds like
an arrangement that's like that's a cute
thing to happen for like someone who
like works and lives in like Brooklyn
and like her and her boyfriend like work
at BuzzFeed you know anything like that
would happen but like now for like a
rich woman you know
two attorneys who clearly like are very
logical so it made me feel like their
marriage is an arrangement it's like
it's a sham yeah it's weird that
conversation she had with Tamra on the
hike first of all you could tell that
she was like panting so much and I was
thinking like that would be me if they
asked me to be a housewife and the first
scene was a hike I'm like peace I don't
want to be on the show
so I could tell that she was on struggle
said he wears a camera like owns a gym
she's a fitness kind of competition
competitor like I was like this poor
girl I was like dying about it that's so
me like she came in like full hair and
makeup right first see no no I was
thinking I'm like this would happen to
me like and she wasn't wearing
sunglasses like I could see the Sun
beating on a torch but it was obviously
so arranged cuz they were like talking
about the last time they saw each other
which was literally six years ago right
and then like she met Ricky at that
party and became friends with him in
Gretchen like so weird hi Ricky's out of
control we still talking about Gretchen
when he comes up every season good for
her I think like even though I hate her
and she was so crazy like she doesn't
have justice because she made that show
what it was you know totally remember
Jeff
she was shocking like Jeff I yes no but
I actually like liked her because it was
it was so crazy and like her being like
a young thirsty gold digger attaining
like a old dying man was like so that's
why you see like I just was so crazy and
that's the type of thing I want to watch
on TV and I never not married so he
didn't she didn't get anything from him
no all she got was like a line of
handbags I don't say one that's buying a
mega a joke it's like $75 but are you
kidding oh my by it's not worth if
you're like one Instagram laughs no like
as a joke like to literally put on a
shelf on ours actually if we did that it
would be worth for sure but like we
don't have we need show yeah we have we
don't have the load-bearing walls we
need shelves to get like some of our to
get some like props for sure but like so
I managed what would be a good way if
someone is an interior designer
let us know I really want like a shelf
with like some of our most prized
possessions totally but like our gobbles
omelet we need like like a display
similar to watch drop-ins live I just
feel like we have so many post house
yeah a toaster so someone is a designer
let us know like what we should do maybe
like floating shelves but that's not a
real wall I know it looks like it but
it's not anyways I think that's enough
Oh see
not nothing happened this season looks
like it's shaping up to be good oh my
god when Kelly is naked and falls oh my
god like I was watching a Mac I got
she's my my body was physically shook by
it that's great that's like what a brain
is she really does
they all her in Tamara and everyone
looks yeah
Vicki's new face is smiled Vicky and
Steve what's Brooks like it's like
here's here's my problem with Nikki
she'll be in an interview when someone
will be like do you ever talk to brick
she'll be like who's that never heard of
him on reunion who I don't know him but
and then she's talking to her new man
who loves her and she's talking about
Brooks come on he's a catch he is a
catch but like there's definitely
something weird there definitely I don't
know that there's something weird let's
just leave it at that
yeah no okay let's do the Bachelorette
because I watched are you the first half
and obviously I watched the wrong first
half cuz it heard it went down in the
second half and I'm gonna need you to
tell me what happened but I was like oh
my god I didn't watch oh no I was on my
crowd oh my god oh my god working like a
dog it was like 8:30 I guess I could
just put it on so I'm like in the know I
saw the first two hometown dates with
literates you guys I've never seen
before I was like who are these guys
Jason who is like weird but really cute
like he really likes her but he's a huge
freak like I could just like the way he
was talking about his brother's marriage
his brother and his husband I've like
the best marriage like the way he was
talking about it was so he's like I just
see them and I'm like oh what a great
marriage like it was just so weird I'm
like okay stop like he was glove with
his brother um and he was like oh he was
doing something so weird when he said by
the back he like grabbed her pieces like
every time I see you I can't something
not when I'm gonna see you again and
every time I kiss you I can't stop
thinking about what I'm gonna kiss him
again and every time I said touch he'll
kiss up to me okay I'm gonna touch him
again I was like okay this guy the poet
like has to go um and she like it's just
not she's not there you know um oh and
then the second guy took her to his high
school who was it Blake
cuz it's not guarant it's not Colton
okay Blake yeah we just wake up the long
edge hair who was the longest Jason okay
yeah that's everyone to make sure Jason
was right Blake took him to his high
school I was like the coach the pictures
on the wall and I was thinking to myself
before it was over I'm like there's
literally nothing more lame than like
you have a count
crew and the world watching what do you
want to show them what's your best
moment high school like what's sadder
than that but then I realized like ten
minutes later the reason why they did
that it's because he was at a school
that had a school shooting he was so
crazy like it came out of nowhere he was
like school it wasn't like a like a
well-known one but wait hold on I had
something to say it came out of nowhere
it came out of nowhere
[ __ ] wait I had something to say school
shooting came out of nowhere you were
like why are they showing this to us
yeah he might have nowhere that he told
you that it was a school shooting yeah
that's as far as he got oh because he
was like I already told Becca you know I
guess he had some that he was divorced
or something one of them's divorced
Garret okay the place I hate this
[ __ ] job
wait was Garret this guy no no no he I
know Garret he opened up and told her
something and he was like I feel really
good but I got something else to tell
her and I'm like and he kept saying him
still nervous to say this thing it's
like oh he's like what is it and then
he's like a school shooting I'm like
that is not the same as like opening up
about like something that's wrong with
you you know right it was so dramatic
and like I don't know the show is
getting out of control and I don't know
what happened at Colton's hometown date
but spoiler alert
I know Colton went home okay yeah which
makes sense because he's going to
paradise and he can't make top three or
it makes sense
oh [ __ ] I lost my bracket and I'm
[ __ ] pissed but Tia shows up in left
eye's episode I don't know the oh my god
okay right and I think they like trot
off to Paradise together I think but
that's just the vibe I got my Twitter
thank you do I know then I was like oh
is everyone hating me I was like I
watched the two terrible hometown dates
and I really I like Garrett and I love
Colton people are saying that the first
hometown was Garriott maybe he turned it
on 8:30 in the middle maybe who was like
the long hair like behind his ears yeah
maybe I miss Garrett's okay and miss
Garrett's in the beginning I 1 2 & 3
because it was Jason and Blake and then
I miss Colton which was like really
annoying
[Laughter]
pisses me off so much was like he wears
it behind his ears no and it's like a
girl 180 he curls up behind his ears and
like I honestly like I'm not here for it
but like it's 2018 like you're a
good-looking guy you're clearly cool
enough to make it to Final Four like why
you vampire bro we will I need to find
out what happens with Colton and we'll
recap it tomorrow but we have to talk
about something else bachelor related
also apparently Colton told Becca he's
the first girl oh my god I saw this
machine's girl he brought home and then
there's all these pictures of Aly
Raisman in Christmas onesies whatever
maybe those at her house for angry
nobody wait let's talk about the
absolute atrocity that was the pure Wow
exclusive with Becca Martinez actually
got it honestly good for Pierre I'll
forgetting that article because it gave
me so much joy those pictures were so
fake like I can't the article she's so
fake like the whole thing is a sham a
shack she's basically saying that she's
not going on paradise because she's been
in like two secretly relationship for
months I just think she wasn't asked
about Paradise and like doesn't want to
be embarrassed by that and has a fake
boyfriend told or maybe it's a real
boyfriend
well what she said is like they started
dating in February she kind of like left
him on the back burner because she had
dreams of going to Paradise and she
didn't go to Paradise she's saying
because she decided she wanted to be
real with him but we're saying she
wasn't invited to Paradise and so now
she's then she was like okay I'll take
you it's like a bird in the hand is
worth two in the bush she went for the
two in the bush but the bird in the hand
was still waiting for when she got back
um I disagree I think there's much more
to this she seems really sleuthy and
like ever since that whole
raven twitter drama like i am getting
the vibe that bachelor nation bachelor
producers don't like her and i think for
one reason or another she wasn't asked
to go on paradise and I think that
everyone thought she was going to so she
actually come up with an answer so she
did like this weird exclusive no one
else has ever done an exclusive as to
why they didn't go on paradise right I
think she really thought she was gonna
be asked and she wasn't right I just I
really wish she was to see if she would
have shaved her armpits good cause like
I was really excited because and
honestly like if she shaved her arms for
Paradise I was gonna meet disappointed
meet you like because I could fight the
patriarchy be consistent and like do it
on national TV like really like what
better platform right that's the only
disappointment that's so true I did
anything about that
imagine like if she was in mating
student like a man has to decide like
that would be really actually socially
relevant but no no we get clean shaven
armpits from all the other girls
no that is insane
like I can't believe what I was reading
as I was reading it no I know and like
all the pictures with the filters it's
like it was FIFO magazine like oh yeah
she was hoping that those pictures would
that have been people know but like
she's not on that from Paradise
therefore she's not even relevant
she's random as hell so I will not
honestly like I won't be missing her on
this season of paradise I'm very excited
for paradise like I will be watching
consistently live tweeting like that is
a show I can get behind
I totally agree and I just want watched
and called him together forever except
like after talking to Raven like there's
no way they're together right now and
that just breaks my heart
however maybe he followed you to a
closer to cinch that is so mean never
get closer to me well he knows you're
married woman he's not like that so
hurtful he's not like that one he's a
good Christian boy I'm sure he's a fan
of been like he's not gonna go
underneath woman in this present moment
in real life he's had sex yet no do you
think he was lying about being a virgin
because in that book they say use extra
jumbo tampons but I can't happen if I'm
happy flow and a wide-set vagina
no because Raven said she believes he's
a virgin and I leave Raven medjool and
Raven also said hurt him and T I never
had sex so that means if he didn't have
sex with TIA it hosts paradise he and
having sex
what are your feet what are you thinking
for bachelor we're almost there okay
here's what I think three here's the
problem absolutely no one is invested in
the season so even though there even
though there are good guys um and I
don't want like I'm pretty sure I know
who wins so I don't want to like spoil
it by saying who doesn't win okay so you
don't say
Jason step the vampire is definitely not
so would either be Garrett or Blake I
think they'll be the final two so it'll
be one of them as a bachelor but no
one's invested enough in this season to
even give a [ __ ] if one of them were to
be coming back I don't think they're
gonna go with someone from but I don't
think so either because they keep tapped
the last two bachelors have been not
from the women season right and re and
they're there's no way they're gonna
choose someone from the season cuz no
one even cares about this season but
like okay when they chose um Nick after
whose season Jojo
it was like I didn't see a better
alternative uh Luke or chase meh
meh Luke would have been a good factory
even though he's a thirst monster
general and fake as hell nick is worse
but when they did re
instead of Peter like that was a big
mistake yeah so I understand why they
tapped on Nick
I shouldn't have in Nick but I
understand like them not wanting to give
it to chase honestly like seriously and
like even though I wasn't in love with
chase after Jo Jo season yeah no me too
but like as a bachelor I don't see it
now because we know too much about him
and he run X's and packs on the beach
and that's bad right so like I wonder if
they're in tune with what's necessary
they know that we really don't care
about the people that are currently on
the show and it would now would be a
good time to tap on someone old like no
so because uh we some innocent Ben
Higgins we've heard bachelor sorry so
it'll probably get it I've heard rumors
that there were it was Ben Higgins and
I'm so here for it I saw a picture of
Ben Higgins playing golf in this like
snobby golf tournament and he is
literally the biggest house I've ever
seen you have to look at it it's crazy
Eamonn I'm Ben Higgins number one
Supporter now would also be the time for
Peter right but I think Peter there's no
way he's gonna do it also like there
were rumors team it's like seeing
someone and he's spoken ill of the
franchise a lot and like and Mike lies
cuz he really doesn't care it must be
nice
must be nice who else could it possibly
be who was runner-up on like just like
Rachel season out Peter who's runner-up
on joto season oh those thirst monsters
yeah all these guys we know way too much
about them right maybe they'll bring
back Brad Romek again no we're like
someone from Kaitlyn season then Z yes
that's a pipe dream oh it does he yeah
and here they tore out he was on our
show they're really real and he's
fantastic and I love him
someone from Kaitlyn's season they're
all pretty much coupled up now cuz Jared
Ben Higgins from Kaitlyn's Yvette
Higgins
yeah or Peter or I guess like Blake or
or an exile again know if they did okay
ready if they gave Nick Mile The
Bachelor ship which they're not coming
to but if they did
wait what about Colton he's with Tia no
I don't think they're together oh then
I'm here for it oh my god then that
would be incredible and he's a real
celebrity like I was thinking they
should get a real celebrity and I think
that's why they brought Carlton on the
show to begin with so we could have a
real celebrity bachelor oh my god that
would be epic and Margo is going on a
hundred percent will Center updates up
but does gonna say if they do give Nick
Val the job you and I and the toasters
we're organizing a protest like we're
gonna make signs and stuff and we're
going outside a nice
see office uh there's one of the city Oh
ABC is Hearst 57th oh great
love of the 50 protest total I there's
restaurants okay that's totally fair
okay we are organizing a protest now I
almost want them to give it to Nick so
that we do organize protest yeah that
would be fun I think they would never
though Nick was so so bad
vile yeah but he did bring us amazing
girls but anyone would have brought
those girls to us it should have been
Luke imagine if Luke and Raven we're
often sunset together I'm glad we didn't
the best I'm glad they didn't there's
like I couldn't watch
miksa season without being like this
should be Luke and Raven and Luke are
meant to be together but now it's it's
funny things change
let's I'll show you those terms Nana na
mind this is our so this is still our
show southern term Savannah is not
southern charm Charleston
this episode was go though they brought
in two new cast members who are very in
tune with what's necessary Brandon is
fabulous as hell and hey good is the
what is like the southern woman that
Shep has been dreaming up his whole life
except like she like they'll never meet
but I have hope and Daniel still the
best comeback I was going to say I'm so
not interested in watching the show
except I'm in love with Daniel I Colts I
know and he's like such a business man
but it's like he doesn't even go out
with the boys anymore really like he
wakes up at 6 a.m. to like work out go
to work and he's like if I'm going out
with Ellen brand and like I'm not doing
any of these things so it's like he's
fine like everything we want from Shep
and Craig is like happening to Daniel go
Tim you know go Daniel thank you guys
for watching this has been the morning
toast which is the Millennial morning
show we will live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time and we're
recapping talking about all the things
you really care about the Kardashians
The Bachelor - on musk basically
anything he wants to talk about will
dance for you
we're back tomorrow that's it face by
you